[Music]
[Music]
like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday this
Thursday feels like a Friday because
there's no show tomorrow due to the
Labor Day long weekend which I'm super
excited for so happy Friday happy almost
Friday it's Friday Friday gotta get down
on Friday when my song came out and like
I really stood on YouTube and like all
the YouTube trolls came and they're like
it sounds like Rebecca Black like is an
insult I'm like that's why I was [ __ ]
good so thank you yeah and not only like
was she a one-hit wonder which is the
dream but now she's like a full-blown
influencer and she's pretty beautiful so
so again united we stand so thank you
okay I see you and I see me a compliment
inside you and I appreciate you it's
been like a really slow week and I'm not
sad that it's ending
I'm so not sad about the week is ending
like at all we are going out with a bang
tonight to the Jonas Brothers concert at
Madison Square Garden yeah I think I'm
gonna lose my goddamn mind
and also bebe Rexha the opener like I've
literally never been to a concert and
seen the opener so like I wonder what
goes on when there's an opener are we
gonna make it for the opener did she go
on we don't know Mario Jackie told me
last night she does want to go know that
I'm just like I'm just not in the mood
to go to a concert at Madison Square
Garden like I can't explain it's just so
much energy I think she's like couldn't
be easier it's in the city it's not
about with great sense it's not about
than getting there it's like you're Ames
she wanted to know lucky I'm like on
concrete just like dancing in your seat
that's what a concert I don't know you
don't have to tell that you don't watch
not like it's you don't know you can see
you know what I mean I wouldn't mind
having the extra chair like empty so I
could put my person yeah honestly I'll
let you guys know so don't feel don't
feel pressured no I don't and I know
like I'm gonna have a great time if I go
I'm just like almost not in the mood to
have a great time you never know what's
really okay I know I get that
you know it's like I jealous but I just
want to lay in bed
yeah I'm back-to-back concerts I'm ready
to [ __ ] roll my face off we got
tonight Jonas Brothers
tomorrow night in Dallas Rascal Flatts
like and I actually think I might looks
just like we're seeing back-to-back
trios
think about that and I'm just ready to
something about it something
thank you for tomorrow we have a pickup
truck what are you doing yeah and we
have a flat one yeah who's driving if
we're gonna tailgate um someone will
have to exactly doesn't drink nobody
actually said that he wants a drink
what's her a shaker let's do it that's
what I think you said this like small
startup in the Hamptons called like lily
pad or something that basically was a
service that drivers would ride a
scooter or gonna pick you up at the club
if you like drove to the club they would
tour their scooter in the trunk and
drive you home and then they drop you
off at home and take their scooter back
to wherever they need it to go which I
thought was kind of like a really smart
concept that is our concept we do we
need a chauffeur but then it's like
whoever comes it can't be said we want
to talk about the eyes yeah it's like
why are you coming to the show oh my god
I'm going to die wait so like we're
gonna tell you eight like what do you do
at the tailgate I've you I've never done
the bed of your truck you like put out
your drink let's get let's go to Walmart
and get like I'm like an inflatable
mattress something so we can make it
like comfortable in the bed of the truck
you know okay well and then we also have
to get a flag pole
are you bringing the toast well of
course I've been dreaming of this my
whole life
everything about this do you need a
parking pass to tailgate I don't know
hold on I'm gonna get moving like by
those in Ticketmaster but you're jealous
and you're gonna in national cap no
that's that why it's the only thing I'm
jealous of plus I've been to Rascal
Flatts so I really can't be that jealous
but it's just Margo's
first time in Nashville right now
Nashville virginity identity those
commercials Colton is running like are
horrible and for his sake and the sake
of his family and everyone who knows him
I hope he got paid six million dollars
for yeah that's the only thing that
would make me feel about know I think
anything below a million I would have
said that me too Benji I have
morningstar veggie burgers I ate one the
other night and like it's not doing
anything positive for the brand for me
no check every time you eat it you're
like I'm using baby genies
yeah I'm like having sex with a veggie
burger I do it was so stupid I do with
my neighbor's I do with my friends I
wish I did it sooner yeah lose your
virginity today it's not good not good
it's not good and you know someone like
got promoted for that because they
thought it was such a good idea yes
and I'm sure they're still like you know
we killed it like you can we kill it
totally they did kill it um okay oh my
god I have to tell you the most
embarrassing thing that I did yesterday
it's in there you know I really need to
stop drinking cuz like when I do I just
get so brave how many drinks do you have
three Wow
margaritas I was having such a nice time
with TPG I never see him and when I do I
never give him one-on-one like it was so
special and I was like asking a million
questions about like how I become rich
about business ya know I was really
asking about like business if you get
any answers on how to become rich I did
actually okay I'll tell you bout him
later so what I was sitting and I saw
Steve gold from million dollar listing
who I love and he came over him Estonia
it seems show me pictures of his baby
and he smelled so good I literally just
wanted to like take a nap in the deck
and then like cheese drinks later I
suppose and so the way that the
restaurant is set up there's like a
men's room a women's room and then right
outside the men's and the women's room
there's like a big mirror so I'm walking
to the bathroom and Steve gold and his
super cute girlfriend are taking a
mirror picture and what would a normal
person do like wait for them to finish
it in of course they jump in the picture
but she didn't know who I thats more
normal that gets worse pretending you
don't know them no of course I got in
the picture I was like it's fine I know
Steve I'm sure she hears that all the
time she was confused cuz like but like
I was like I just looked to see if I've
minutes ago like let me in the picture
and I'm like tagging on Instagram and
then I'm like walking away into the
bathroom and it seems like you're going
into the group and I was like thanks
Steve I was halfway in the men's ER
before Steve pointed out and then it
went till later but the men's don't
think God was up day but it was just
like so bad I think for like my
boyfriend seems like see me that way you
know yeah you know and like you
embarrassed yourself like in front of
twice in front of his main chick I'm
like yes I checked so like I'm I can't
be brought out in public it's so scary
yeah I just don't worry leaving your
house is so underrated like cuz I never
do it I saw so many celebs I saw Adrien
Brody it depends where you're going like
you wench was starts with a a
star-studded place last night and but
like it's there's nothing sadder than
when you like you muster up the courage
to your house and you go [ __ ] nowhere
to like Loserville and see nobody has
even bidelman and nobody cares about how
cute you look what a waste
ya know the star-studded evening I felt
like super cool I like hated my outfit
what were you wearing just like an ugly
shirt hey you know it's like it was like
a big bus t-shirt that made me look like
a [ __ ] hello I saw your cue a big
breasted woman oh yeah that shirt was
cute and I like that you match this your
earrings it's like a fine shirt okay
well next time maybe not maybe not the
shirt yeah I'll leave the shirt at home
Oh give the people that pull up are what
they really see that was just like my
embarrassing story that like I tried to
forget before I went to bed I understand
well I'm glad you're bringing it back up
and of course
servicing into today well if he woke up
with like so many pits because I had a
crazy dream
meet you where I actually woke up with
tears in my eyes but it was like it
wasn't bad but my dream was that like it
turned out like mom finally told us that
I am adopted and it was my dreams are
like so real it was so everyone like
reacted as if we would normally react
like we were just like we were like we
were just so happy about my button and I
was just like thinking to myself I said
all this time I just felt like this was
my family and like we may do and you
know it happened to turn out great but I
was like no like I'm so lucky that I was
chosen to be in this family like surgery
what if things didn't happen that way
and I started crying like in my dream
and I woke up and I literally had like
tears in my eyes that is so huge
different dream and I was like really
confused I was like and then I'm already
thinking about all the people who have
like written like he's Jackie adopting
that I was like so excited that I could
go respond yeah yeah my to my dear
friend Mia Marga were pushing you out of
the business she didn't she I mean maybe
I'm dreams were interesting I always
want like I honestly wish people's
dreams were anything it's like if I had
a dream the mats I'm sick I wish that
meant that they had a view about me too
yeah but like I've had many Egyptians
made no [ __ ] sense anyway so like why
not have that and it's crazy what dreams
you remember like I will never forget
the dream that I had where Zac Efron was
my boyfriend and like it was the best
night of my life and I woke up like next
to Ben and I was like so upset I'm like
what the [ __ ] are you doing here like
we're a sec a prawn I'm like though
those kinds of feelings that really stay
with you know when your dream life is
better than your real life it's such a
sad place to be a sad place yeah I also
had a dream like earlier this week that
my hair was really falling out a lot in
the shower so I
I felt like that might mean something
you know like that's a common theme
that's definitely like a super and so I
looked it up and it means like you're
worried about like you know aging and
not being like vital like you once were
I'm like yeah that seems fair
well I everyone I have to pay and so I
wake up every morning remember but yeah
and I'm convinced and I peed the bed
because they always feel the feeling
like I have to pee what do I do you
should google what that means I did and
it kind of made sense but then also like
one of those I tell us what it said I
don't remember so we kept and then one
of them was like well do you have to pee
but I don't i peed before bed nothing
worse than being dead asleep and having
to pay like [ __ ] off I've seen times
like really think about just peeing the
bed just so I could be put out of my
misery yes but not having to get up I'm
not someone wants to pee in the middle
of the night and I always like pee right
before bed so that's not even a problem
see I'm one of those people because I
always forget to drink water during the
day so when I'm at home at night before
bed am i oh let me just drink some water
because I forgot to do it all day and
then it sits in my belly and I wake up
like with a full bladder it's the worst
someone said that they're big on dream
journal and you learned so much about
yourself I'm sure you really do like I
feel like when you wake up and you
immediately forgot your dream it's
because like you should forget to dream
right you're urinating symbolizes a
cleansing and a real release of negative
and repressed emotions depending on your
dream context urination is symbolic of
having or lacking basic control of your
life you are literally so true
you're literally pissed off and not
expressing yourself in a positive or
constructive manner Margo that is so
appropriate and I feel as though you've
kind of figured out your life right
there yeah yeah I also feel like the
subconscious is such a [ __ ] yeah
there's no way they wrote that how do I
trust them yeah and like my subconscious
like it doesn't think I don't know my
subconscious wasn't thinking about being
adopted maybe it does that's so so but
then I literally thought I was like but
I did 23andme and I was like well my
birth parents must also be hundred
percent right who are they
that would be an extra key like Annie I
was like where are they
ah so no come on
Oh tomorrow okay well I feel as though
we've analyzed her dreams enough to to
launch into the past five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
spoiler alert you don't really need to
know these stories they kind of suck
yeah it was a slow news day but thank
God we have tons of new content coming
out from the real world Facebook watch
because the morning chose today is
brought to you by MTV's the real worlds
Atlanta streaming now only on Facebook
watch the original reality show is back
and streaming now with only only on
Facebook watch MTV surreal world Atlanta
is the next true story of seven
strangers picked to live in a house and
have their hookups screw ups apology
Speights tears voices and lives live
streamed exclusively on Facebook watch
it's the return of the first unscripted
show in TV history that tackled gender
race AIDS taboos life death addiction
connection acceptance and reality and
it's being reinvented MTV's the real
world Atlanta is an all new reality
experience with content dropping daily
and new episodes every Thursday find out
what happens when the next generation
stops being polite and starts getting
real again in facebook click on the
facebook watch icon and search the real
world on watch MTV's the real world
Atlanta's Schumi now only on Facebook
watch so new episodes dropping today
it's actually such a great show and I'm
living for it being on my phone
living for it we just love watching
stuff on our phone like it so true all
right let's dive right in tell me the
fast fact that I need to know that you
that you like couldn't know right I'd
survive without think you'd survive
without but might be good to know what
are you going to the Rascal Flatts
concert oh you know what I've been
thinking because I'm so glass mummy went
a few months ago I got up an oversized
t-shirt rascal class I was like maybe
I'll wear that with like a high pony
sure but then I also just ordered like a
bunch of stuff online like cute cheap
clothes and I might do like a pink
cowboy vibe cute so we're meeting them
right our way I thought we have
meet-and-greet but they're so early okay
no but like I really want a photo with
okay well then you know back to the
truck after I actually think you can if
we're gonna be their tailgating anyway
might as well yeah I just
can we tailgate was like a like a
portable air-conditioner like there are
tailgating companies that like do luxury
telly oh my god they did it on um real
houses in Beverly Hills never liked any
set that whole thing up yeah oh my god I
would totally do that
okay all right if somebody needs outside
oh oh
I'm gonna driver wait okay that's
totally worth paying for it okay what
was a betting on how much of this yeah
okay first story
speaking of tailgating LuAnn de Lesseps
says she's staying sober after probation
she's officially off of probation so she
released a letter about it that was
incredibly confusing and I wasn't sure
whether the the letter was to
acknowledge a year of sobriety a year of
probation or she was leaving the show it
was very ominous so feel free to raise a
glass in honor of LuAnn reaching the end
of her one-year probation but forgive
her if she doesn't join you she's
planning to stick with the sober life
The Real Housewives of New York star was
on TMZ live Wednesday to talk about her
milestone the judge offered ordered her
to stay off drugs and alcohol during
probation and LuAnn told us it's had a
profound impact on her life as you know
she's been on probation from her
Christmas a 20-17 arrest just like not
that long to be on probation
especially because didn't she break her
probation like multiple times yeah but
so overall it was one year I think she's
been you know in the court system since
Christmas 2017 that's a year and a half
that's a long time yeah you know so do
you think she's in a surgery and I mean
she said that she won't and while I do
believe her I think that she will
because if she was drinking while she
was on probation right also like she
couldn't drink because of probation it's
a similar like Kathryn Dennis situation
like you got in trouble because of drugs
and alcohol does that mean you're a drug
addict and an alcoholic right not
necessarily but if you can't go the year
of probation without having a drink like
maybe you do have a problem maybe maybe
I mean I I don't know but I like if
someone told me I couldn't drink for a
year because like I would go to jail
like I would not drink yeah I feel that
she's like like the threat of jail is
scary enough for me like I love to drink
and I drink a lot probably more than I
should but like I don't feel like I have
a problem because I could do that do you
know what I mean yeah that's how low by
Boris yeah but like say you're pregnant
and like you're not supposed to drink
but like you could sneak in a drink oh
my god I would never but like you can
have a drink while you're pregnant
yeah actually this is a hot-button topic
right now I was actually reading some
threads about it because like you
technically can't have like a glass of
wine a day and there are a lot of women
who do and then there's like mom shaming
for women who do I don't think I would
just because like even though you can
I can live without it you know I don't
really I would want to take a tequila
shot I'm pretty sure I can't do that you
know right I don't like wine anyway so I
don't think I would do it all so like
I'm just so like afraid of fetal alcohol
syndrome like I have so much anxiety
about like me not knowing that I'm
pregnant like before the first month and
like just drinking my normal amount like
at a club and then finding out I'm
pregnant if I didn't know and then like
just the baby have fetal alcohol
syndrome doctors don't tell you cuz I'm
sure they don't want to encourage it but
it's like if you drink it's if that were
to happen it's okay okay yeah
like obviously people get pregnant like
people who are blessed enough to just
like get pregnant accidentally ya know
there's crossover for sure and you're
thinking and but at that really early
stage it's okay good to know
um and this came up on southern charm
reunion last night which you didn't
watch uh video I was about with Steve
gold when you were watching million
dollar listing right in living color so
no everything's Technicolor this is what
seems I'm a hey hey hey
I'm happy for Gwen I think you know this
boats her very good season um Liz hi
posted in the toaster yesterday that her
sister was out of moxie
and they're filming and Bethany is not
there and you know if they're at the
Moxie it's going down yeah and it's uh
just a bunch of drunk videos of Sonya
and Dorinda and it's good but like I was
talking the TPG about this last night
cuz he's really like a housewives
fanatic too and like we were talking
about like how worried we are like how
crazy it is like it hasn't said in that
Bethenny's not coming back I'm like I
just so nervous for what the new show is
gonna be yeah I think it's gonna be off
the rails which is sometimes good yeah
but but Bethenny was there to like keep
it in line while being off the rails I
think a like OC is off the rails but you
know what that's the that's their
franchise that's their brand whatever
like Beverly Hills is on the rails like
there are things people won't say in
steel even when Camille like uttered a
word about finances like you know so I
think New York has always been like a
Beverly Hills where they try and say
highbrow but I think we're going low
this
I think we're going extremely low
because Bethany was really even in terms
of just overall looks like she always
brought a look she was really one of the
only ones who like has money not from
the show yeah and she just brought an
element of class Grace and an elegance
that I will really dearly miss but I
think one of the new housewives is a
friend of Tinsley's which means we keep
tensley which I like she brings a look -
yeah and I'm here for a friend of
Tinsley he's like an entrepreneur I read
which is very big either means
billionaire or unemployed I'm hoping for
billionaire because I can't I'm not I
don't feel like watching the financial
struggles on a show that's supposed to
be aspirational and it's really a she
that's retiring about oh say husband is
still in the news and by the way he got
arrested and that's why he lost his job
not her his arrest for like domestic it
domestic violence so and now it's coming
out like what's in his bank account like
he has a hundred thousand dollars in his
bank account in seventy five thousand
dollars in severance and it's like why
do i why do I know that like why am I
being judged into this no I know and
they're so messy OC and like none of the
ladies like we went from there was a
time in OC when everyone lived in a
gated community and a McMansion that
well they all looked the same now it's
just like I'm no one to judge was I
don't even have a house I rent an
apartment but still like I watch these
shows because it's supposed to be
aspirational I want to see Bentley's and
and you already this thing we think show
you so honey and say when you want to
enter she had fancy cars and jewelry and
like that is something I can walk I I'd
rat I'd prefer jeane over pad me too
they used to like post the prices of
everything that they were doing now they
go to like some boutique on Rodeo Drive
and buy a million things for eight
hundred dollars twenty five thousand
twenty three sunglasses twenty five
thousand there used to be me we're in
the heyday of like the money of it all
in like now some franchises like for a
while OC was I mean not to say New
Jersey was like very rough like
everyone's house was getting foreclosed
everyone's husbands lost their jobs and
it was like a recession literally in New
Jersey now OC is getting that to you
like Tamra's only one who's slightly
moving on up because but that's money
from the show like yeah I want to see
family wealth yeah like Erika Jayne was
such a welcome to Beverly Hills before
you even knowing about her she had to
bucking planes and her husband is a
famous lawyer he was in a movie yeah I
need a plane per franchise me too you
know one day knows he has a plane no one
in Jersey has a plane no no one in New
York City nothing doesn't have a plane
she charters planes but you know that's
good night
that's like Randall I'm it good enough
for me yeah and like before Erika Jayne
had a plane Lisa Vanderpump and Yolanda
were always chartering so well yes a
jury got on the plane to the Bahamas
they gray I need at least like one real
private plane like not wheels out per
season yeah totally Oh see how did you
bro got the amount of wheels up plain
once and it was so small I thought
they're going down yeah yeah I need like
the real deal once the season
yeah that's such a great call I don't
think the warehouses in New Jersey have
ever flown private anywhere I don't
think the Real Housewives are those -
yeah well they do did they did the
heather dubrow wheels up one I kind of
understand why heather dubrow left like
as much as I love her now just
evaluating all the franchises she is
like so above OC yeah and now her
husband's on TV they don't they just
don't mean it and I think they have like
so much going on between her YouTube
series and their book and their skincare
aligned with the QVC like they got it
all yeah okay their goals
next up speaking of someone whose goals
Kelly Clarkson reveals another health
scare the cyst on her ovary burst while
she filmed the boys painful Kelly
Clarkson takes knowing how to grin and
bear it to a whole new level
the star 37 who will be kicking off her
new NBC syndicated talk show on
September 9th so excited talk show hosts
that support other talk show hosts in
like she's so deserving she's so funny
and she's she's the real deal
where's she in a film at in a show I
don't know I think so because I read an
Archie was on the cover of peeple
yesterday saying how like the the only
way she agreed to do the show is if they
would prioritize her dropping her kids
off at school yes so then so then
Nashville right to LA or New York right
open up - I couldn't see her in you know
not about she's too wholesome to be in
this [ __ ] full of disgusting this
she opened up to people in this week's
cover story and shared that after
pulling off the major feat of hosting
the Billboard Awards with a burst
appendix back in May
she suffered yet another painful health
scare and again on live TV at the
Billboard Awards quote I just didn't
want to leave people hanging she says of
how she managed to belt out numerous
hits with a smile throughout the live
show on may 1st I Jackie and Lonnie
we're at with her doctor's aware of her
condition and standing by at the ready
she really pushed forward I was just
thinking about trying to relax she says
but in reality I was in so much pain
after undergoing emergency surgery right
after the show oh I think we didn't know
that heart disease healed quickly and
was back on screen just a week later
filming live show
for the voice but the superstar singer
reveals pain struck again as the cameras
rolled Blake Shelton was talking to me
and all of a sudden everything he said
just went away and I had to grab his arm
and I was like something is wrong and
that's when she learned it was more
painful than appendicitis it was
literally a week after my surgery so she
was freaking out
damn oh my god Blake Shelton is such a
good friend I was giving you a shoulder
to cry on yeah and then arms grab you
makes you stronger I love her she's
still married to Revis son yes yeah her
managers who she's married to
yes Reba's the one who got divorced from
them yes oh yeah so Reba was her
stepmother in law and now she's not cuz
right yeah it was the kin but her and
Kelly are still so close yes thick as
thieves thick as thieves
I in the words of Caroline Manzo thick
as things a Kelly Clarkson should host
like CMA Awards yeah she would be great
because she's so good at billboards
she's not country but she's not not you
know like she's in the scene she could
be country if she wanted to she not
country no when someone told me like
without her most recent album the one
with like piece by piece someone was
like it's not country and I don't know
why I just like I assumed that it was
cuz she like was in Nashville and isn't
related to Reba but it was the most
shocking thing ever like just to hear
that Kelly Clarkson was a pop singer
because she's not the p-side piece album
was popping her most recent album the
meaning of life is actually more like
soul yeah I'd say gospel yeah yeah even
more like R&B than in his country she's
just across genre like [ __ ]
oh really talk show and the [ __ ]
Billboard Music Awards but then
appendicitis spurts yeah I hope I really
hope her showed as well me too I think
it's such a great like choice from NBC
because she is so like all-american like
she's a real American dream story coming
up on American Idol she is in like the
country space but she's also apparently
in the pop space she is like a mom she's
super relatable like she's not super
like high fancy like you know she goes
to Target like I am so excited for this
I could really see her becoming like a
staple of morning and daytime television
and like having her be on TV for 30
years and like this is where her career
goes for the rest of her life I mean I
hope so I think that's what everyone's
hoping for it's unfortunate because I
love her and I want to support her but
like I just can't watch I could
time to talk to you every day I will
watch it I will watch you just did like
make sure she's doing well but like
that's just not I just hope there is no
difficulty none be uploading everything
to youtube yeah well I looked at the
profile for the new show and it looks
very fun very purple they have a nice
flow going
which gives me hope hasn't even
premiered yet
I know how's it been talking about for
so long for literally a year yeah but
then like Jerry OH got his show in ten
minutes in ten minutes I think it must
have been I mean TV is weird but also I
think Kelly like needed to get ready for
it like with her kids and make sure
everything's settled and like do it all
so Kelly's is a nationally syndicated
show which I believe takes a much longer
time to like that means every market has
to like bid on there's like a whole
thing like it's super hard Jerry's I do
think his regional like I plays on
different times on different stations
like anywhere in the world you turn on
Kelly at 4 o'clock it'll be on it's like
Ellen so I do think that takes a much
longer and much harder to get off the
ground then Fox which is where Jerry
always I think got it and it looks like
it is filming in LA ohokay
crazy sommelier sees if Jerry Oh shows
doing well I watch I followed him on
Instagram he does like really funny
segments yeah he's just so funny and
he's like trying super hard like he
wants us to work yeah I need to like go
get my nails done on the place that
plays it you know better they valley say
that that's how I'd watch any talk show
like Harry Connick jr. Billy um Billy
Idol on it was a great segment by the
Harry Connick Cheers yeah his show got
canceled
two years ago we got invited to go and
literally the day after I was cancelled
so the place I get my nails done at now
please New York one which is really
pertinent Today Show and like I love
supporting Roma and the gals um and they
learn a lot about the city through that
yeah um but I'm not learning about my my
up-and-coming talk shows and and how IMG
live is doing
ya know me harder when Tia nails
yesterday and they only play New York
what am i - lon I normally I watch it
but I have to say I was telling Ben last
night so because I've recently only
started to get a gel manicure I would
say I get him out of care of once every
three weeks and I've started to make it
I used to dread getting manicures like I
just find it so tedious like my back
hurts hunched over like it's just it's
torture have to wait there's so many
politics but I've recently started to
like treasure those moments because I
have like a routine now I go to fresh
and go and I get salmon and rice and
then I bring it upstairs
I get might be done and I'm just
enjoying my feet eating my salmon doing
my listening to music maybe answering
some emails and then I'll go get my
manicure and I started to get a back rub
during the manicure and it's just it
makes him out of here fly by its shell
enjoy a back rub I do it the entire time
whoa and I mean obviously it like makes
my entire experience there like double
the price but I started to just carve
out it's it's this is what I think it's
like no time I think what this is what
people are talking about when they talk
about self-care like is sitting to your
body
listen like I have just decided till I
can make my nail salon like my happy
place and yesterday like I had the best
time Marta came with May we both ate
salad bowls i okayed any salad but
whatever um then I got the most
incredible neck massager I fell asleep
like in a manicure chair like it was
such a happy time for me and I feel like
that's why I'm in such a good mood today
like self-care is is the only care
that's what I'm saying yeah how can you
take care of others if you can't take
care of yourself yeah no it's just like
I used to just dread it it's like that's
how I feel where I'm just like I'm so
anxious and impatient I'm like looking
at every crevice yeah I don't even want
to look I didn't even look until I got
up yeah but it's like how even if it's
whatever like it's your [ __ ] nails
are so chipped right now but from this
camera like they look great they do look
like - a fresh manicure where there's a
crevasse who gives you a terrible
experience but I'm I heard Margo and I I
got Margo up ten minute backrub because
I was living in meditation for me oh my
god she this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] cheap
listen no I didn't want I don't like
getting the massages so she was like she
said get it like it's on me I was like
okay like whatever so then I go to pay
and I was like and they charge me for it
it's like oh I thought it was on you I
didn't want a massage she'd already paid
I forgot to pick up this bitch's $13
massage the principle I wouldn't have
gotten one I don't like to I tried to
give her the ten down the thirty now
she's like no way to take it Martin oh I
said let me give you catch me like nah
because it's just stupid so why do you
just live saying that oh because you
were like I'll give you the money - did
you get your wallet out [ __ ] I was just
shouldn't get you to [ __ ] relax which
is obviously you need to do look at you
well speaking of relaxing I actually
wanted to share an interesting factoid
because yesterday
my upper back was hurting where it just
always hurts if you're a woman with my
breasts and I on my Bureau was the CBD
cream that the judges gave us the VRS
CBD and had he tried to get judges by
that's like my confusing Tamra yeah
judge Tamra gave to us and I hadn't
tried it yet I'd never used CBD cream
and I was like this is for pain and I
have pain so I put it on my upper neck
and I have to be honest like my pain
went away really yeah
it wasn't like such merry no no but the
pain wasn't like so crazy bad I don't
like I wouldn't recommend it for like
you know search tree but just for like
those moments of pain when you're
feeling a little sweet it really works
Wow so I just thought that was
interesting that is very interesting
thank you for sharing yeah okay next
story shark tank judge Kevin O'Leary on
boat in collision that killed two oh my
god it's a fatal boat accident and now
he is he's in the crossfire
mister not so wonderful entrepreneur
Kevin O'Leary who was best known for his
appearance in the hit TV show shark tank
was involved in a nighttime boating
accident that left two people dead his
agent told CNN the incident happened
over the weekend in Ontario Canada
O'Leary was a passenger in a boat when
it collided with another his agent Jay
sure's said the agent told CNN that
O'Leary's life when life okay Oh Larry's
wife Linda was driving at the time life
went oh yeah the collision left a man in
the second boat dead said Joe skyleigh
spokesman for the West Parry Sound
Ontario Provincial Police a woman in the
second boat succumbed to her injuries
Tuesday police said a passenger in
O'Leary's boat was also injured police
say three other boaters were injured and
were treated and released from a local
hospital no charges have been filed
Linda O'Leary was given a DUI test which
she passed the quote or Leary's agent
wait that is so crazy so sad and I don't
know why people go boating at night
honestly like I hear about [ __ ] like
this all the time like remember that
really young baseball player who was
like gonna be super famous and he just
died in a boating accident and I'm like
I just I can't stress enough how like
boating is dangerous enough like let's
not do it in the dark and this is like
so crazy like I don't think there's
anything this is like I don't think
there's anything worse then like being
involved in an accident we're somewhere
like someone else dies I mean yeah like
crystals right but he was drinking at
the time so like I can I actually do
blame him we
ever talked about on the show but he got
his sentence of two years suspended
sentence which means I don't know but I
didn't mean he shot jail time it means
he's not going to jail I feel conflicted
about it because like I love crystals
and he's like a hot dude
but also I just I can't see past the
fact that he was drinking and driving
and killed someone and like I don't know
why we're giving him a pass but he
wasn't he was driving a tractor it's
like it's a weird no he was driving a
car the guy was really guy was driving
the track oh he was in a smaller car and
still managed to feel someone and then
fled the scene I'm sorry I just I know
he loved him but like why are we talking
about it like it's not an awful thing
because like yeah [ __ ] terrible he
killed Kenneth emotions he was it was a
really tragic accident right because he
was strong I don't think he was so cut
and dry like that
I don't remember being like that I
remember being like that but people
aren't talking about it that way for
some reason I like he had beer and he
left
yeah and Kenneth Mosier died sorry about
you don't remember anything but you
remember his name
I mean I remember his name Jim because
it was such a terrible story because he
literally died for no reason because
Christos was being an [ __ ] sorry like
I don't know why I can't say that you
can is that how you feel about the
O'Leary's well they weren't drinking
it's just well these are two people who
shouldn't be driving about at night you
know what I mean you can't see anyone
I'm sure they literally just crash right
into each other
I do boats not have headlights let's see
I just read in the comments I turn off
this ship and apparently the other boat
their headlights weren't on oh so I
don't know I don't know if that's true
though that's so crazy I mean this is
like such a horrible story and this is
not wonderful service for wonderful and
like everyone loses because people are
dead people are injured in other people
are [ __ ] traumatized I just don't
know how like Linda this like nice rich
lady just [ __ ] killed someone
I certainly how they died like how do
you crash into a boat that then you die
you have flung overboard and then you're
unconscious in you drown yeah if I had
to imagine yeah that makes sense
they had to be going so fast right it's
just like idiots like I who maybe I'm
just jealous it on up a boat but I just
can't imagine getting on a boat at night
obviously I would never yeah but people
do it like it's not forbidden thing like
and boats have lights it's like saying
don't drive at night hmm it's not like I
isn't cut and dried but like you can
never there's a row he's harder to see
yeah
sure you know like the roads are made to
withstand nighttime like the ocean
doesn't have traffic lights and but
there are some roads that don't have
traffic that don't have them like road
lights overhead lights okay a lot of
roads yeah but they have yellow lines
that reflect they they have everything
there's always something that like the
headlights pick up they're reflecting
yellow lines or the white lines or the
traffic signs are meant to be reflective
that's why they're so bright not every
road notice there are pockets of roads
that don't have any for sure but I'm
talking about roads in general there's
not a single traffic light or a stop
side or anything in an ocean I think
boating that's dangerous on the Reg okay
that's fair that's your position yeah
well the GUI does not a traffic light
make no but yeah it's not at all we'll
keep you posted on the story really sad
for everyone involved totally um very
sad
okay next up some business Hudson Bay's
is selling Ward and Taylor for a hundred
and million a hundred million dollars to
clothing rental service that tote
Hudson's Bay will be made ninety nine
point five million Canadian dollars
seventy five million American dollars in
cash after the Idul closes and secured a
promissory note of twenty five million
payable is basically Lauren Taylor is up
for sale that's so clear they sold to a
smaller rental fashion company oh how
the mighty have fallen like a new and
younger Lord and Taylor was [ __ ] it
and now it's so crazy I have a piece of
Lord and Taylor in my home isn't crazy
oh yeah when I moved into my apartment I
had such big walls and I wanted like a
fancy art piece and like the one I liked
was twenty five thousand dollars like
obviously that wasn't gonna work out
mass's right and I ended up Olivia told
me she watched best Lord and Taylor and
her him Zack winning because they were
having like a going-out-of-business sale
and it wasn't what she thought she
thought they were just gonna be like
selling clothes they were literally
selling chairs from the dressing room
art off the wall so I went in and I
bought a piece of art it's [ __ ] huge
and was a hundred dollars amazing now
that I should be on extreme couponer
couponing you should be that's pretty
cool it's pretty cool just another sad
like he'll giant right another
brick-and-mortar failure yeah it's like
that analogy we can never think of it's
like one loss for brick is another chip
in the computer exactly and this is so
pertinent because this is not an ad but
when I went to dinner with TPG last
night he told me that he uses Robin Hood
to invest and I was like oh my god so he
really got motivated me that I get back
on my Robin Hood flow I swear this is
not an ad and he was like honestly just
invest in companies say like you believe
in so I bought like a bunch of stuff in
revolve last night it's so smart and
like I don't understand how they make
money but they keep doing it so yeah I
wanna I just I need to now that I have
all the business like from reading the
paper which by the way I haven't been
able to read the paper since last week
the yellow journal and I saw the yellow
journalism and now my paper comes and it
gives me a pen yeah baby sign up for the
paper and I otherwise oh my god you know
it's like one of these muckrakers want
today yeah and it's like oh if they tell
me about a business that's going under
but maybe it's not they did this whole
thing on GE that it's fraudulent but
then people are saying that's not true
I'm like so do i short sell GE or not
are you gonna short it I don't know
what's the truth I don't know but all I
know is they better be right about how
great sent bird is because they're truly
the greatest basically it's a perfume
subscription service where you can
choose from like fancy ass designers
like Prada Tom Ford Versace they have
more than 450 designer brands for you to
choose from perfume and cologne
you choose the one you haven't tried
they'll send you a 30-day supply which
is basically a bottle of 120 sprays
which is enough to apply four times
every day for a month and then the
subscription ends you go the next month
you can get a different one the same one
replenish if you're not sure what type
of say you're looking for you can sort
and find your new fragrance by brand
style occassions season and more if you
check out their user ratings for reviews
on any fragrance so basically it's hard
to buy a fragrance online but they have
tons of reviews pictures of people who
had used it before what they thought it
smelled like what they liked what they
didn't like you but like basically you
get to test any different perfume you
don't have to invest in a whole bottle
because I curfew marketing like really
makes no sense if you can't smell it
right with an exclusive author offer
just for our listeners you can get 50%
off your first month today at scent bird
calm slash toast that's only seven
dollars and fifty cents for your first
fragrance today go to scent bird comm
slash toast and sign up for 50% off your
first month
again that's scen TBI RDECOM slash toast
do to try your first perfume or cologne
for seven dollars and fifty cents
sinon smell amazing totally also before
I forget we need to talk about Dave
Chappelle's stand-up special which we
will do after the fifth and no one let
us forget it is too important it is too
important I agree okay
fifth and final story a little more
business and a little more retail news
because forever21
prepares for potential bankruptcy
filings why because I think they're a
cash cow I don't understand how this
there's always people in there yeah I'm
like um they could they could even be
fully online and not have great pay for
those you know rent spaces on 34th
Street no but they really kill it like
in all facets like their social is so
good they make such cheap clothing like
hmm Wow sure forever21 Inc is preparing
for a potential bankruptcy filing as the
fashion retailers cash dwindles and
turnaround options fade according to
people with knowledge of the plan so I
guess if they're public like this is
information right that the stocks going
down I'll check it on Robin Hood the
stocks going down the company has been
in talks for additional financing and
working with a team of advisors to help
it restructure it's dead but
negotiations with possible lenders have
so far stalled the people said focus has
shifted towards securing a potential
debtor in position loan to take the
company into chapter 11 they said even
as some window remains to strike a
last-minute deal that keeps it out of
court I mean even if it's out of court
is like still things are not going well
over there very sad very surprising very
surprising because out of all the retail
giant's have withstood the test of time
forever 21 to me was always one that
like really transitioned from retail to
digital super well then change their
stores that have the biggest stores
everywhere you I've never been to a mall
that you're never forever 21 is honestly
a red flag because that so much you have
to be selling so so yeah but when a
brand is going bankrupt like you see
them the closing stores you know I've
never seen the forever any mall I've
ever been in it's like the forever 21
this brand new huge and so many people
you can't get a check out they
overextended me maybe I don't know I
feel there's so new age there I wouldn't
even compare them to like a Lord and
Taylor they're like very much of the
millennium
you have a Lord and Taylor like it
doesn't surprise me just because like
the type of clothing they had in Lord
and Taylor was just not keeping up with
the times like it was very much like an
old lady store which is good but it's
not gonna be a multi-billion dollar
brand like forever 21 like their shirts
were so on I'm talking about them like
but but everything they make is so on
trend and so relevant and like they we
didn't like when I went for Coachella
and stagecoach a glittering forever21 I
shopped everywhere forever21 had
everything I needed yes but just cuz
they're filing for breakup she doesn't
mean they're going at it right it's like
this is a difference it's like it makes
no sense I mean Drake tried to explain
it I'm Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
but they're just like they probably just
want to not have to pay their debts or
their loans or whatever right I think it
all gets forgiven if you file for
bankruptcy right yeah something like
that
so sounds like I need to file for
bankruptcy yeah totally so I they'll
still be around but I just can't believe
they're even in such a weak position I
go anyways those were the Fast Five
stories like I said they were I would
say they were kind of slow yeah they
were medium those Lopez stories I'm okay
I want to talk with the Dave Chappelle
say I'm special because I watch it I
told you to watch it and then Mario came
over yesterday and I tried to get her to
watch it and she wouldn't get off her
phone it was so frustrating something
you need to be so annoying how often do
we say you have to watch no I plan to
watch it just like wasn't the time and
she was just wait being literally insane
like I would call my phone first second
check Nick are you watching you guys are
you watching you and it's like not like
you were attending to business like I
literally saw you like checking random
notifications and like scrolling it sort
of like you weren't actually so it's
training it was trying to get someone to
watch something when they won't like pay
attention is the most frustrating to
watch I just like didn't want to do it
then like I had to I could only watch 30
minutes add to leave it three like it
was stupid I could watch it on my own
time and enjoy it yes you just like
wanted to so hun do something nice I
didn't know you'd be so crazy by a
charity case and I was trying to expand
your mind I'm gonna live in make a wish
I wish that Margo will watch it and take
it seriously but actually I did
something that when Zach came home I was
like you need to watch this and usually
I say that and I watch him watch it like
it get off your phone cuz he's always on
his phone but I I went to the other room
while he watched it and he said he loved
it I don't know if he was paying
attention but I feel good well so I was
like feeling so crazy conflicted about
it and I did have posts in the toasters
because I watch it like me and Ben our
jaws were on the floor like there was
some stuff we couldn't stop laughing at
and then there was some stuff that I was
like oh my god I literally cannot
believe those words just came out of his
mouth I know I was feeling so conflicted
because while I don't really condone
like making jokes about sexual abuse I
totally understand I don't think he
actually feels that way I just think he
because we live in such [ __ ] up
like he needs to say stuff for the sake
of being allowed to say it a hundred
percent and like their jokes it's just
it's okay I loved it there was so much
stuff that it's like oh no that's not my
personal thing but like the r.kelly
stuff that was so funny
like the Michael Jackson said it's like
I don't agree but like I can enjoy this
this is hilarious and like it's just
funny like everyone there's this thing
now where it's like you can't say
anything that it's almost like you've
committed a crime right which is like
the First Amendment it's freedom of
speech saying whatever the [ __ ] you want
like so I just like loved but even when
I personally like didn't agree with it
it's like I'm not offended like he
couldn't have made fun of white people
more I'm not offending right it's
[ __ ] hilarious and even if I don't
agree like it's just a joke no and
Jackie well I think it was so important
and every child should watch it like
it's such an important generate well so
I felt incredibly woke after watching it
because he made probably the greatest
point ever we okay I want to hear what
you thought it was for me the part that
I thought like what was the greatest
point it was talking about how like the
crack epidemic which really affected the
african-american community people would
just regard them as like criminals who
do drugs but now it's like heroin is
affecting the white people and now it's
like they are sick they have an illness
we need to take care of them oh it's so
[ __ ] sure I was dying laughing at
school training for what happened it was
like it's a kid goes to school now and
because I just cool shootings there's so
much a part of our culture like they
have these jurors in place where it's
like every now and then they'll do a
drill in case what happens when there's
a school shooter and he was saying but
like the school shooter is in the room
for the training so it's like where we
meet enough he's like we're giving them
all the secret yeah it was any take as a
parent like we all look at each other
knowing like one of us is raising the
school shooting well yeah it just
doesn't want to be me ya know it was
just all so funny and like all of that
stuff is so taboo but this is like
reality and like we have to be able to
joke about stuff no I couldn't agree
more
and also like oh sorry the best part of
the whole thing and I watched it in two
parts and so I watched the entire thing
and then I watch the last ten minutes a
day later and I'm sorry the last ten
minutes were the best part at first I
had no idea who he was talking about
when he was talking about the French
oh yeah I had a little idea he was
talking about the French actor should
say smoothly a and I was like who the
[ __ ] is this guy talking about and it
occurred to me like literally 10 minutes
later he was talking about justice
mullet the French actor and any time he
talked about his name he was he
pronounced it differently so he was like
she's La Salette and oh my god
I couldn't stop [ __ ] laughing so
funny I mean just really like he totally
gets his audience when he was doing the
Nigerian accent it's just like and it's
so much of the stuff he's talking about
really is like a weight on on this
country like total shootings in it and
it's and it's it's really painful but
like laughing a brand it brings like a
little levity to the situation like you
feel important laughter is the best
medicine like you're you're listening to
it laughing and like feeling guilty
about laughing which makes it even
funnier no a hundred percent and like
really like the Jessie smell that [ __ ]
is so crazy and like it's so crazy but
no one has like made fun of it where
it's like right for the pickings wait
people I'm putting in the comments like
things he said that made me laugh that's
too hot for TV he's like I would never
say that I mean if you didn't seem
especially I don't know what we're
talking about it's it's under an hour
it's so funny and also just like
watching I mean he just did so many
shows in New York I can't believe we
didn't go like I'm so accessible I had
no idea how important it was no me
neither and like I know some of the
stuff he's saying like is show
off-putting to people and I just can't
stress enough like I hear you and I
totally see you but at the same time
like I totally respect and like love his
point which is like okay you don't have
to agree with me but you can't kill me
for saying it right
you can't like cancer he's like our
crusader against canceled culture and
I'm so I'm so here for him it's like and
he really he's talking about everything
like everything everything it's on
Netflix it's called sticks and stones
this sounds like an ad for it but it was
just so funny it was so funny and I just
think it's important to be able to make
jokes about anything because they're
jokes and you should be able to laugh
and you should be able to laugh at
yourself laugh at other people like it's
fine but can you imagine being so
carefree like I would SPECT the hell out
of that like he doesn't give a [ __ ] like
I do an episode of The Chosen every day
and whatever and said by me and how mad
they were about what I said about the
opioid epidemic and then I can't say
because I think everyone hates me and
thinks I'm stupid like I am so in my own
head I'm so self-conscious I have so
much self-doubt and he doesn't give a
flying [ __ ] and it's so impressive it's
so impressive and like the Kevin Hart
stuff he was just like I thought his
takes on so many you know topical what's
the word that controversial [ __ ] yes
just refreshing because everyone says
the same sense did you see that Vice
article that was like don't waste your
time watching date Chappelle's stand up
like that that's just proving his point
yeah prutte and people just went in and
if you look on Twitter it's like people
really enjoyed it I think he speaks for
a lot of people who are really set up
with like the fact that no one can make
a mistake
no one and it's not even about like
making a snake like committing a crime
yet no you can't do that but like you
can't say something out of line which is
like it's not the best thing to do but
it it's not a big deal right just work
and it's called growth it's just it's
it's crazy so I thought I thought it was
really great I was really happy to he
was so funny okay if you are a Florida
chaser like I hope you're doing okay if
you need any resources there is a
Florida toast your group join I know
people like opening up their homes if
you're I don't know how bad the
hurricane is but it's Florida hurricane
season so just lean on each other and
our toasters in the Caribbean I saw some
of them are posting there are two
they're all me yes I think it's an
international show is that stupid show
we've been international yeah well I
mean we're big in Toronto yeah so
alright so I hope everyone can you know
make it through the weekend lean on each
other join the Facebook group it's
actually super helpful for resources
thank you so much for listening to the
money a morning show the morning shows
we go live Monday through Friday and
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube feel
free to give this video a thumbs up and
subscribe if you liked what you saw
maybe leave a comment we're also
available to podcast as you probably
know an iTunes Spotify stitcher
literally anywhere you can listen to
podcasts so feel free to subscribe over
there leave a 5-star review about how
beautiful smart and like hilarious we
are we love you so much there's no show
tomorrow because we are going to Dallas
but we were recording an amazing patreon
episode for toast radio today so
basically so exciting episode will be up
tomorrow and it is basically our top
we're each gonna pick five songs or so
that we really love and so it basically
if you're listening to his podcast in a
car it's like a radio station we're
gonna talk in between saw and South the
so you can listen to music you can
listen to the chose all your loves in
one place I think it's a really good
idea
and I think if people like it we'll do
it that's like a monthly I love to
because I just love to share music with
the world right and also talk about why
I like certain songs also the newest
episode of the snatchler is out we
recorded the yesterday honestly I think
the snatcher is like like brilliant
stuff sometimes I did you really get
into like this sociological issues
within the bachelor yeah um chase Bertie
McNary really liked it he commented on
the snatch I've never sent to the
podcast and he listened to the podcast
because we were like kind of roasting
him but we were roasting like we were
really just being honest about like him
as a human with huge thighs in a good
way and crazy like you could say that
about like a woman and it means
something so different than when you say
it about a man totally like if anyone
ever referred to me as a girl with huge
size like I would literally stab them in
the back yeah but like chase Brody
McNair he loved the fact that we pointed
out his huge size yeah guys if it's so
good it's good enough for him it's good
enough for everyone yo check it out the
snatchler love you guys we're back
Tuesday
you